hey I'm Lauren London sitting here with
don't sheets I'm a jury I wasn't even
looking at the question okay take two
hey what's up I'm Lauren London and I'm
sitting here with amazing
Nipsey Hussle the gray this is the GQ of
couples quit are you ready let's do it
he's always ready see he stays ready so
he doesn't have to get ready you got the
script down you know babe I'm an actress
istic yeah what is my favorite movie of
all time
you got like through it folks of all
time though the one I'm always like one
day it's all going yeah can I hope
that's right that's right yeah that's
right you got one one for us um what is
my favorite color if you ever told me
that but I'll just say red I never
remember you saying it's my favorite
color purple for my phone I got that
right - okay you did you're always right
it was never like we had that combo dish
my favorite color so this is just some
[ __ ] we gotta establish now five years
and now he knows the Purple's my
favorite color
who is my celebrity crush y'all tell me
no stuff like that I had to tie
boyfriend
he's a girl be like this my celebrity
crush so she says probably that's some
[ __ ] you know no you I don't have a
celebrity crush I'm with my celebrity
crush right go blue dress whatever you
guys ain't got no celebrity crush
me nice questions yeah come on what's my
favorite nickname to call you one right
yeah what was it a my BAE but all right
I call you have described my perfect day
or date how we gonna tell it is right
though I mean I'll tell you if it's in
the ballpark I mean you were like
somewhere for a good play this and like
nature yeah right how did you where did
she write that down though how did you
check that like if that was right it's
an internal so she just telling me if
I'm right or wrong
yes what was the last book I read there
you go Seiko a woman yeah yeah I'm in
told me what's my cell phone number I
don't know it it's 2018 I think about
that too like cell phones remove no
numbers my heart so I already know
nobody do you know the area code 7 1 8
my next question if I could travel
anywhere in the world where would I go
yep yep this one you better get right
who was better with cross no that's
wrong about say you the next question
what was cross his first word that was
odd to me in the same window
they were dad that was his for sure
what's my favorite food to cook for you
my favorite I mean I think it's the same
sargol yeah what's my guilty pleasure TV
show mob lysosome shave my wife's
housewife the housewives yeah where did
we first meet and what did I think of
you the first time we met she was head
over heels sprung from
but a first time in person don't crash
on Slauson I must or yes but what did I
think what did you say you thought or
what it no what do you think I think I
thought she was head over heels
committed and ready to run right so you
got half of that right it was not how do
you say do I like spicy or sweet better
spicy what's my favorite flavor ice
cream chocolate vanilla chocolate
strawberry was you know it's cookies and
cream pregnancy dreams which I don't
what's your favorite this might be kind
of hard
what was our most memorable date hard to
tell you what it's a noble and we made a
dare that you jump in the ocean so close
indeed yeah
you know I lost those Karen Walker
that's exactly what's my middle name
James [ __ ] you what's my middle name no
I know that okay what color are my eyes
what was my first acting job
oh you using soul playing yes you got
cut I was in so plane as passenger
number two and I was cut out if I can
live anywhere where it'll be malleable
yeah what's my zodiac sign yeah
what am i the most comfortable sleeping
in yep what's my shoe size small now the
light I don't know four three four I'm
killing it bro I'm betting like it's out
I mean
what's my favorite thing to order at
Starbucks since you've been with me you
copy my order locate no I'll do a
cinnamon Dolce hey I'm good down there
got all of this [ __ ] right I mean I'm a
harder answered my question that's 40
okay what's the best way to make me mad
oh okay I think about that type of thing
honestly you gotta you know think like
that what's the best way to make money
ignoring my texts yeah that'll piss me
off
what's my favorite part of my body if
he's gonna sound real arrogant in value
face that's a part all your nose like
you know I like my nose what's your
favorite part of my body yeah I'm gonna
say yo the foot lady fake on camera
what nicknames do i call cross podium
that's really a man and papa bear woody
came out of like I don't know who knows
something mama [ __ ] okay what's my
favorite song of yours don't give a [ __ ]
yeah describe me in three words
this is turn to Lauren praise
charismatic force or I'll say like
honorable emotional okay that's that's
honest you actresses none wrong what's
my favorite thing about you
that's a long list yes and the favorite
one no I would say what my spirit and
that was my last question
excellent amazing you know me I'm not
surprised
uh we'll be back for how well she knows
[Laughter]
these are funny
[Music]